[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'historienne annie cohen-solal pour son
livre un étranger nommé picasso éditions
fayard un gros livre de plus de 700
pages qui nous raconte la vie du plus
grands peintres du xxème siècle sous un
angle inédit son statut d'étrangers en
france où il passera pourtant toute son
existence fichés par la police suspecte
indésirables et incompris mais d'abord
on commence comme à chaque fois par une
image symbolisant notre époque
voici alors celle où pluriel que vous
avez choisi annie cohen solal
voici la première à houston alors c'est
là la chapelle rothko la chapelle du
peintre marc rothko construite avec lui
et pour lui par la famille de mesnil
d'origine française dominique demèny les
gens de mesnil
c'est une chapelle octogonale en béton
qui a été construite il ya 50 ans
précisément et qui est juste précédée
par un obélisque brisé de son ami
barnett newman dédié à martin luther
king
donc il ya quand on entre dans cette
chapelle on a déjà l'image de la lutte
contre la discrimination raciale aux
états unis et à l'intérieur c'est
absolument semble n'y a pas une fenêtre
s'est illuminé par le haut il faut
s'asseoir
il faut attendre et il faut que ça qpi
s'accommode à l'ombre et là on commence
à découvrir les 14 panneaux que roscoe à
pain pour cette chapelle et ses panneaux
vous attire en eux
parce qu'il ya des des commandes
directes des rectangles des rectangles
coloré qui flotte comme il faisait tout
le volant quel type ses oeuvres les plus
seuls
voilà et ces rectangles vous appelle il
y à une ya pas de cartel sur les murs y
a rien d'écrit
il n'y a pas d'hôtel y'a pas de mots et
c'est une chapelle nom des mêmes domi
nationale c'est délicat elle est dédiée
à tous les cultes et aux gens qui n'ont
pas de religion et c'est un lieu qui est
entre l'art la politique et les tic et
roscoe avait créé ses oeuvres en pensant
à une chapelle qui aime qui se trouva
sur une île à à venise et disait que
c'était qu'il y avait pour lui une
tension entre la tragédie et l'espoir
donc ce lieu se situe
qui a été créée il ya donc il ya
cinquante ans est complètement en phase
avec notre époque parce que c'est
l'artiste qui permet aux visiteurs de se
ressourcer de se recentrer et de se
situer par rapport à ses deux pôles qui
sont tellement présents aujourd'hui la
tragédie et l'espoir
la deuxième photo s'est inscrit ce taux
c'est un ami à moi que j'ai découvert
quand j'étais aux états unis qui mord ya
juste un an qui était une petite
merveille d'hommes il est née en
bulgarie qui était un des satellites les
plus brutaux de l'union soviétique il
est quasiment partie à pied
il s'est enfui et cette oeuvre là c'est
sa dernière grande oeuvre spectaculaire
c'est sur le lac d'iseo en italie près
de bergamo et ce sont 4 km de pontons
flottants il appelait ça floating piers
une sur sur le lac donc de loin on voit
quelque chose de sublime mambo on voit
cette couleur orange qui flotte sur le
lac qui entoure l'île du lac
et puis quand on marche dessus le ponton
faisait six mètres de large et il n'y
avait pas de barrière il n'y avait pas
deux d'endroit où se tenir
donc on marchait sur l'eau et on avait
les vins qui venait lécher le les bords
de ce tapis rouge orange et on avait
l'impression d'une précarité donc
kristen n'a jamais voulu mettre de
messages c'est un artiste conceptuel
mais néanmoins le message c'était un
message que personne d'autre ne pouvait
passer
c'est le message de l'immigration de
celui qui traversent les mers c'est de
celui à qui je dédie mon livre à
l'artiste qui aujourd'hui est en train
de traverser la méditerranée sur un
canot de fortune ou d'emprunt de
traverser l'afrique à pied c'est un peu
le statut qu avec picasso en 1900 et
quand on marchait sur ses pontons
flottants
on avait cette ode au delà du lbo on
avait cette impression de précarité et
qui était incroyable et enfin un
troisième s'est garni qu'à de picasso
c'est tellement son oeuvre la plus
célèbre
c'est moi celle que je préfère c'est une
immense une immense toile qu'il a fait
en trois semaines
alertés au moment de la guerre d'espagne
par le premier massacre de civils dans
une petite ville basque qui s'appelait
gwernig à un jour de marché ou non été
tuées par une légion allemande la légion
condor et une légion italienne par deux
de deux types de lésions fasciste par
l'aviation à l'aviation des populations
civiles qui était au marché
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le premier
massacre des civils dans le monde
contemporain et la picasso qui devait
faire le pavillon espagnol pour
l'exposition universelle de paris en
1937 et qu'il y avait d'autres idées en
en quelques minutes ils se fixent cet
objectif il va reprendre des thèmes
qu'il avait pris avant on voit on voit
on voit une maternité on voit un cheval
on voit un taureau on voit une lumière
on voit une femme qui lève les bras et
on voit des corps démantibulé et c'est
devenu l'étendard de la résistance à
tous les fascismes cette oeuvre à
traverser aam voyagé dans le monde
entier pendant cette année pour lever
des fonds
pour les républicains espagnols et
aujourd'hui elle se trouve à la au musée
reina sofia de madrid mais c'est c'est
peut-être quand on demande et alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est une
oeuvre noir et blanc c'est une oeuvre
qui lui a été dans laquelle l'a beaucoup
aidé beaucoup aidé son ami de l'époque
qui s'appelait dora maar qui était une
photographe surréaliste cette oeuvre
c'est comme une photographie surréaliste
il a emprunté beaucoup à dora maar qui a
fait des photos mais est en fait
aujourd'hui quand on demande à des
immigrés que les l'oeuvre d'art à des
immigrés syriens par exemple aujourd'hui
dans des camps de réfugiés qu'elle est
l'oeuvre d'art qui représente la guerre
tout le monde cite guernica de picasso
cc c'est extraordinaire comme cet homme
a saisi l'époque et a saisi un moment de
l'époque qui aujourd'hui est toujours
d'actualité puisque aujourd'hui la syrie
c'est le guernica 2009 137 m et bien
commençons
[Musique]
nikon solal vous êtes d'historienne vous
avez consacré des livres mémorable jean
paul sartre ou peintres américains ou
aux marchands léo castelli cette fois
dans un étranger nommé picasso aux
éditions fayard
vous vous êtes attaqués vous êtes
attaché plus tôt à suivre les pas du
plus grand génie de la peinture du xxème
siècle qui a été donc ficher toute sa
vie par la police française à qui on a
refusé sa demande de naturalisation
alors qu'il était déjà une star
internationale et dont et les oeuvres
pourtant célébré dans le monde entier ne
sont entrées dans les musées français
qu'après la seconde guerre mondiale
alors qu'il était déjà vieux il avait 66
ans
alors pourquoi tant de haine de la part
des autorités françaises à l'égard de
picasso c'est quand même incroyable
je dirais pas que c'est de la haine mais
bon et je vais vous et je vais vous
reprendre frédéric et avec deux oeuvres
de picasso dans les musées français
2h 2h qui n'était pas grandiose une à
grenoble et au musée du jeu de paume
c'est tout ce qu'il peut pas parler de
haine
on peut parler d'eux d'abord la la
précarité de picasso dans la société
française son statut pendant 40 ans on
peut dire que il avait il était marqué
d'un triple stigmates et ce n'est pas
particulièrement entre lui la première
chose c'est qu'il était étranger et que
la france sortait de de la période de la
chaire dreyfus de grandes de grandes de
grands attentats anarchistes y compris
contre le président de la république qui
avait été assassiné par un anarchiste
italien se dit carnot voilà et alors
donc la police était sur les dents la
police était très puissante
la police française a été construite
pour être une des plus belles polices du
monde et la police regardez envoyer des
indicateurs de police dans des quartiers
où il y avait des étrangers hors picasso
je me suis interrogé pourquoi at il dû
venir quatre fois de suite à paris de
1900 1901 1903 1904 pour pouvoir y
rester
paris c'était la lumière du monde pour
les artistes et le seul endroit où il
fallait être donc il arrive à paris mais
il n'arrive jamais seul
je me suis demandé pourquoi parce qu'il
ne parlait pas le français parce qu'il
ne connaissait pas la culture du pays
donc il vient avec des copains de
barcelone qui sont catalans et depuis 20
ans les catalans habité montmartre donc
il va habiter chez les catalans à
montmartre mais montmartre comme c'était
le lieu des catalans c'était aussi le
lieu des indicateurs de police qui
repéraient les allées et venues de tous
les catalans de montmartre donc picasso
pour le second voyage qu'il fait parce
que très très très tôt il sait qu'il est
un génie tout le monde sait que c'est un
génie
à barcelone tout le monde sait et dès
qu'il vient la seconde fois il vient
faire une exposition à la galerie
ambroise vollard ce qui est extrêmement
prestigieux et il va travailler donc
chez son marchand c'est le marchand des
impressionnismes dollars bien sûr bien
c'est qu'elle a couvert toutes les
générations précédentes c'est ça il
avait fait don il avait dansé en ses
fonds de tiroir des vendeurs des deux
gars dès maintenant et donc picasso fait
une expression ilan il n'a pas 19 ans il
travaille chez son marchand qui lui a
vaguement signé un truc anarchistes et
le premier critique français dans un
journal grand public fait un papier en
dix ans demain on fera faite aux oeuvres
de pablo ruiz picasso comme s'appelait
encore à l'époque c'est un amant
frénétique de la vie moderne il est
extrêmement doué
cet article paraît quelques jours avant
que l'exposition n'ouvre et puis quelle
soit fait 64 tableaux extrêmement
rapidement que se passe-t-il
le commissaire de police du 18ème
arrondissement voit le nom de pablo ruiz
picasso sur cet article de journal est
très positif et puis se rend compte
qu'il a des notules de ses indicateurs
de police sur pablo ruiz picasso y met
les deux ensembles et concocte un
rapport de police
absolument horrible dans lequel il fait
dire à la critique très positive des
choses très négative dont qui conclut il
conclut en disant pablo ruiz picasso qui
vit chez zone à un anarchiste doit être
considéré comme un anarchiste
au final et ses tableaux qui
représentent des femmes on vient de le
voir des femmes avec leurs enfants sur
les bras des mendiantes doivent être
considérées comme preuve à charge contre
lui
donc on voit ce jeune homme
brillantissime qui ne peut être qu'à
paris qui arrive comme un bolide est qui
dès qu'il met le pied dans la capitale
est pris dans un piège incroyable piège
de la police je voudrais qu'on voit
l'autre l'autoportrait qu'on a vu juste
avant qui date de 1901 également voilà
il a c'est vrai une tête de de
d'anarchistes c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
imaginé parce que c'est une tendance à
imaginer les ponts envoie on voit un
homme beaucoup plus âgé que 10 19
disparus il a 19 ans il n'a pas aimé il
et il a l'air âgé il ya quelque chose de
sublime dans ce portrait parce que c'est
une variation dans les bleus il ya une
espèce de mimétisme avec le fond il n'y
a pas de fond sait pas où il est et il
ya une espèce de force dans son dans sa
corpulence n'est ce pas et en même temps
une fragilité dans le regard
donc on voit à la fois celui qui est
blessé la bête blessée mais prête à
rebondir
moi je trouve ce ce portrait a
absolument bouleversant vous le voulez
mais ce portrait beaucoup énormément et
mais alors ce qu'est ce qui est
formidable dans votre livre c'est que
vous êtes allé aux archives de la police
à paris vous avez tous sortis tous
sortis ou s'ils n'étaient pas intéressés
jusque là vous êtes la première à vous
intéresser à ce un picasso sous cet
angle là donc vous allez sortir tous les
rapports qui sont faits sur picasso au
fur à mesure des années puisqu'il il est
fiché donc on le surveille en permanence
va les sortir sa correspondance ils
parlent mal français picasso il écrit
avec un accent ces lettres sont
extraordinaires anniv
parce qu'il écrit qu'un ex-mari dit pas
ce jeune milieu des cris et voilà il
écrit phonétiquement
donc tout ça est absolument passionnant
on voit que la police le considère en
permanence comme un fuyard un comme s'il
essayait de se dissimuler alors pas du
tout et donc tout cela est complètement
relancée dans la tête et des indicateurs
de police et des policiers
il va s'installer au bateau-lavoir quand
enfin il s'installe à paris s'installe
au bateau-lavoir on va voir une photo du
bateau lavoir qui est à un trou à rats à
ce moment là le bateau lavoir c'est
vraiment la bohème et la bohème de paris
dans ce qu'elle a de plus misérables 1
et martres à ce moment là il va y rester
six ou sept ans dans ce sera dans cet
endroit là on voit le côté le côté
façade le boit le thé le côté jardin
qu'on voit toujours à paris il a été
bien nettoyé et aujourd'hui il ya des
des centaines de touristes devant mai
de l'autre côté puisque c'est dans le
dénivelé d'une commune ça a été
construit à la va vite avec des moellons
des plâtres à des des planches de bois
et des planches de verre et il y avait 1
1 point d'eau pour prendre cinq ateliers
c'était un endroit qui était brûlant
l'été glacial l'hiver et qui était en
fait un espèce de tous disent qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui d habitat
indigne
donc ils habitent là il est très heureux
là il va faire notre toujours la
nostalgie c'est vrai vous avez raison il
l'a dit il a dit oui et c'est ça et
c'est un et s'éteint c'est max jacob qui
l'avait dénommé le bateau la vois pas ce
qu'il disait que le tampon canton ni
bouger tout tremblait
c'était comme un comme une péniche
quelque part elle romano la police
française le soupçonne d'être un
anarchiste puisqu'elle n'est occupé que
d'une chose de sa peinture bien entendu
mais aussi de stratégie tout ça vous le
racontez également détaillé yannick au
sol
il veut devenir le chef de file de
l'avant garde jusque là ça a été très
sympa durer très longtemps ça a été bâti
ce avec les fauves et au fond et picasso
veulent détrôner et tout ça est et il ne
se fait ne se fait pas sans une sans
beaucoup d'intelligence politique de sa
part un picasso c'est quelqu'un qui
résonne sa carrière il peint il pas
énormément il travaille comme personne
mais mais il raisonne énormément c'est
ça que j'ai voulu montrer j'ai voulu
montrer que sa cousine à côté du grand
génie que tout le monde connaît écrasant
ya autre chose
il ya un immense stratège et on voit que
chaque chose et penser il a pensé par
exemple son nom d'abord luis luis a fait
espagnol le louise j'ai trouvé 200
dossiers de ruiz anarchiste archives
nationales
bon alors il décide d'enlever le ruis et
de garder le nom de sa mère qui est
picasso qui est beaucoup plus banal et
qui a une consonance plus italienne
puisque sa mère était de gênes sa seat à
un premier temps le premier geste après
ça par rapport à l'avant garde
évidemment il se ils se il se présente
comme comme celui qui va prendre la tête
de l'avant garde mais il ne peut pas on
ide en 1905
comme vous le dites c'est le salon
d'automne avec l'arrivée des fauves et
mathis qui fait un portrait
sa femme avec un immense chapeau vert
violet jaune etc et picasso à ce moment
là voudraient détrôner matisse mais
matisse à 11 ans de plus que picasso et
geert rothstein la grande
collectionneuse américaine poétesse lui
commande son propre portrait à picasso
or sur les murs de gerolsteiner ça dans
son salon il y a à la fois mathis et
sésame portrait de madame mathis et le
portrait de madame cézanne et picasso
c'est ça que j'ai repéré on est le
premier au 1er novembre 1905 demande à
sa maman qui lui écrit quatre lettres
par semaine pendant 40 ans de lui
envoyer une mantille noire de barcelone
la mer on voit une mantille noire par le
copain canal ce et picasso fait un
portrait de la femme de son copain canal
et le portrait qu'il fait c'est un
velasquez donc quelque part picasso est
incapable de peindre autrement que
velazquez qui d'ailleurs il pas mieux
que velasco à ce moment là alors que
fait-il il récupère un peu d'argent
toujours de vollard qui lui donne mille
francs ils se changent
il va se changer les idées ou va-t-il
dans un village perdu des katas de des
pyrénées catalanes qui s'appelle go zone
où j'ai passé deux étés et ce séjour est
ainsi jour méconnue chez les ch et les
spécialistes de picasso méconnu il a
fallu que je fasse du terrain comprendre
vous allez voir il ya beaucoup
d'anecdotes dans mon livre c'est très
mal ce village est à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
il est au bas de la plus célèbre
montagne d'espagne qui fait le pendant
avec le canigou en france ça s'appelle
la paix trafford
et pour être un homme il faut être allé
aux eaux il faut avoir grimpé sur la
paie de lafforgue picasso arrive à
gossau à dos de mulet 18 km à dos de
mulet avec son ami fernande et ils
habitent ou chez le patron du village
qui est un qui est un vieil homme de 94
ans qui est un homme qui est un
contrebandier qui est à la fois
aubergiste et contrebandiers il
s'appelle pop font de villa c'est un
grand méconnu de l'histoire cet homme-là
picasso adore cet homme et picasso
apprend de cet homme
ce que c'est que la vie des
contrebandiers les savait en andorre
c'est un lieu où il n'y a pas de ya pas
de douane vous savez go seul c'est tout
près d'andorre et les contrebandiers
catalans font passer leurs mules et
leurs ânes
ils prennent des marchandises go sol
c'est un lieu où la police n'est jamais
un prêt et donc pour picasso lui qui
sentait le poids en france de ces
indicateurs de la police allait donner
sa carte d'étrangers allait se présenter
au commissariat telus marque qui lui
arrive et tout le temps tu gagner tout
le temps il
il se il commence à vivre dans ce
village à dessiner à travailler comme un
fou et il se rend il se rend compte et
je prends je pense j'ai pris je pense à
braudel à fernand braudel qui dit la
montagne et la montagne ce tapis pour
jean libre le poids des institutions ni
pèse plus sur l'homme picasso de travail
et son art évolue ça son ca s'ils
voulaient les et portraits qu'il fait
évolué il ne représente plus mais il
présente le visage de son contrebandiers
comme une icône pop un peu il va vers
l'abstraction et un certain moment au
bout de trois mois de se il y avait 200
personnes dans le village terre rien
il écrit sur son carnet indé nord qui
donne la note la plus haute de la
partition - il est absolument convaincu
que c'est lui qui va prendre la tête de
la vendeurs y rendre apparaît
extrêmement rapidement et là ils
terminent le portrait de gertrude stein
ne peut pas terminée elle le met sur son
sur ses murs et avec braque
il va commencer à mettre en place ce qui
va devenir le cubisme entre 1907 et 1915
verser les plus grandes années de
picasso les années déchaînés et picasso
où il va utiliser des outils qui
viennent de là de l'artisanat qui
viennent de là il va faire des collages
et la faire des sculptures
il va tout oser il va s'inspirer de
l'aviation il va s'inspirer de la
philosophie de bergson
il va penser à einstein tout ce qui se
passe dans le monde
picasso le pompe est à la fois il était
à la fois extrêmement curieux
extrêmement sensible et en même temps
extrêmement vampires mais là le cubisme
c'est vraiment le grand moment de
picasso et et surtout qu'il a un
marchand exceptionnelle qui s'appelle
cannes bel air qui est un juif allemand
de 22 ans qu'elle vénère comprend le
cubisme plus qu'à lever l'ère des codes
immédiatement ce que veut faire picasso
il va voir les demoiselles d'avignon que
personne ne comprenait on a parlé de
l'équipe on a parlé tout le monde intel
d'avignon qu'on va voir l'oeil qui vont
rester dix ans dans l'atelier de picasso
à la main voilà donc personne en france
ne comprend très peu de gens me
comprennent canevet les recoupements et
cannes bel air va peu à peu
amadou et picasso et dubuffet marche le
marchand miss
attention attention c'est picasso qui
est très le contrat et kasso c'est le
seul qui ai écrit son contrat son
marchand il s'est aidé évidemment par
des copains parce que ça aussi c'est
très très bien faire c'est un homme de
réseau il a un nombre de copains
incroyable je montre un peu des carnets
les carnets d adresses en face et c'est
extraordinaire
et donc il se fait aider et il écrit
pour le marchand son propre contrat on
né le 12 octobre 2009 112 et la can
weiler fait un travail colossal
il va vendre le cubisme dans tout
l'empiré austro-hongrois l' empire russe
l empire allemand de 1907 à 19
qu'attend c'est la première
mondialisation c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler la police et ça l'a vraiment la
première mondialisation alors qu'anne
weiler vous l'avez dit qui est le grand
marchand de ce moment là et surtout
celui de picasso
c'est un allemand et un juif allemand la
guerre de 14
éclate picasso et espagnols l'espagne
est neutre mais l'allemagne c'est notre
ennemi cannes bel air va déserter i ne
va pas combattre sous uniforme allemand
il va se réfugier à l'étranger
mais en décembre 1914 vous raconter que
la galerie cannes bel air est mis sous
séquestre et toutes les oeuvres de
picasso 800 oeuvres se retrouvent saisie
par le gouvernement veut français en
tant que biens et demi puis ce qu'ils
appartiennent en fin du mois ils sont
détenus par les galeries quatre belles
heures et pendant plus de ça va être ça
a duré sept ans puisqu'en dix ans donc
il reste que dix ans on dit elles ne
seront vendus ses oeuvres à l'encore
bradé par le gouvernement français qu'en
1921 au titre des dommages de guerre en
fait c'était comme picasso à ce moment
là que quatre des leurs est totalement
fichu et et picasso et amputés comme
vous dites de de la plus partie la plus
précieuse de son travail toutes ces
oeuvres cubiste pas du mois de toutes
celles qui n'ont pas été vendus
oui c'est tout à fait juste quel bel air
est victime de cette hystérie xénophobe
hystérie germanophone qui a lieu en
france donc il est le marchand bosch le
marchand et demi et picsou qui était son
artiste fétiche devient victime
collatérale de cette xénophobie de 7,7
germanophobie 7,7
ce traumatisme est terrible pour lui à
tel point qu'il est obligé d'aller vivre
à montrouge pour éviter qu'on ne lui
crache à la figure comme on faisait à
l'époque sur les hommes en civils
pendant la guerre de 14
donc lui il n'y avait pas de raison
qu'ils fassent la guerre son ami
apollinaire qui lui aussi était un pas
qui était apatride s'est engagé
volontaire il aille il en est morte
presque
mais picasso non picasso ne voulait
jamais faire la guerre et et c'est vrai
que là si vous voulez la fatalité qui
c'est qui s'est abattue sur lui à ce
moment-là est quelque chose qu'on a mal
compris
moi je le compris en lisant ses propres
lettres vous savez j'ai passé des années
à courir entre les archives de la police
au pré saint gervais les archives
nationales les archives picasso rue de
la perle à paris les archives de paris
et donc je me suis enfoncée dans cette
masse de documents pour essayer de
comprendre de manière très fine au jour
le jour ce qu'il ressentait
et là je crois que c'est la période la
plus brutale de sa vie il n'a pas
compris et est quelque part tout ce qui
a suivi pendant l'entre-deux-guerres
découle de ça je dirais que pourquoi
picasso après ça et il allait travailler
avec diaghilev pour les ballets russes
parce que c'était un groupe qui était
transnationales et c'était qu'un groupe
qui le connaissaient déjà puisque
diaghilev avait vu les avoirs de picasso
acheté par morozov et schukin en russie
puis après il est travaillé il est allé
travailler avec les ballets détiennent
de beaumont qui était un aristocrate
français qui était aussi d'avant garde
qui finançait des artistes ils soutenez
proust aussi etc et il veut sortir de
nos son isolement en fait oui sort de
son isolement avec alain surréaliste
c'est la même chose voilà voilà
mais en fait les gens disent il a trahi
le cubisme
non pas qu'elle soit ne rien travaillé
du tout picasso de toute façon la seule
chose qui lui importait son art mais la
chose qui lui importe aussi cessé de
vivre et d'avancer or être amputé de son
oeuvre cc c'est une c'est une tragédie
pour lui surtout qu'en 1921 quand on
exécute symboliquement cannes valeur
c'est en 1921 qu'on commence à vendre
les oeuvres que alors que la guerre est
finie que icahn valeur est revenu en
france qui n'a rouvert une galerie à ce
moment obrad les oeuvres dont les
picasso et et sans tenir compte du tout
de sa valeur sur le marché
tout ça l'état français soit les
ignorent totalement le cumul ne savent
pas ce que c'est et tout est vendu tout
à l'heure on parlait de la police depuis
qu'elle se fasse à la police mais il
faut parler aussi de picasso face à une
autre institution dans le contexte
français c'est l'académie des beaux-arts
la france est un pays qui a longtemps
conservé un dd si vous voulez des
institutions qui qui ont été fondés à la
chirurgie et notamment c'est un résidu
de louis xiv l'académie des beaux-arts
et les les gens qui gèrent la culture en
france ont l'oeil rivé sur le l'académie
pour devenir immortel et c'est donc ils
ne veulent pas déplaire à l'académie et
les académiciens sont extrêmement
traditionnel
donc un art d'avant-garde ça fait peur
ça leur a fait énorme extrêmement peur
quand une fois il y avait un un
conservateur qui s'appelait rendrait
désarroi qui avait acheté un picasso et
pour le faire entrer au musée du jeu de
paume
c'est la réunion des musées nationaux
qui s'est opposée elle s'est opposée et
donc quelqu'un avait dit picasso est
honni on ne veut pas entendre parler
picasso il est honni alors
on a parlé des empires de l'est avant la
première guerre mondiale
mais pendant l'entre-deux-guerres qui
prend le relais des empires de laisser
les états unis d'amérique avec le
nouveau musée le moma créée en 1929 qui
a à sa tête le jeune alfred marque est
un historien de l'art extraordinaire
pour lequel picasso et le centre même de
l'art qui est en train de se faire donc
après avoir été très célèbre dans les
empires de l'ess picasso et tresses et
la beauté est très riche
donc il est à la fois célèbres à
l'étranger extrêmement riche et
extrêmement précaire donc c'est un
contraste incroyable on fait une pause
amis collègues solal et or notre
conversation juste après
[Musique]
une cohen solal vous nous avez décrit un
picasso après la première guerre
mondiale donc très riche très célèbre
mais dont l'international a été
démantelé au fond un son marchand a été
ruiné ses contacts dans les pays de
l'est n'existe plus la première guerre
mondiale bien qu'il ne l'ait pas fait a
été terrible pour lui donc il va falloir
qu'il se refasse alors il va
s'intéresser vous l'avais dit à l'est
l'aristocratie française
il va s'intéresser aux surréalistes et
c'est eux qui s'intéressent à lui c'est
plutôt qu'ils s'intéressent à lui mais
enfin il accepte t il accepte parce
qu'ils n'acceptent jamais ce qu'il n'a
pas envie d'accepter
et puis quand on le sollicite pour pour
les républicains espagnols la guerre
d'espagne est déclenché il va peindre
son fameux tableau guernica qui va le
rendre extrêmement célèbre encore plus
célèbres après de picasso après bernard
niquet qu'il ne l'était avant cette
visite qu'on a souvent raconté où il est
dans son atelier arrive des officiers
allemands qui lui disent est ce que
c'est vous qui avez fait ça il leur
aurait répondu non c'est vous devant ce
tableau gacé par l'occupation alors
accession à la libération d'un pendant
l'occupation des officiers allemands
pendant l'occupation ce tabloïd et aux
etats unis puisque il était il est il
était exposé au moma en
1900 en avril 39 et doivent dire car on
sait plus et comme la plupart des
oeuvres de picasso les oeuvres
importantes elles sont aux états unis à
ce moment là c'est là où il a il ne
refaites pas la même erreur que pendant
la première guerre mondiale il ya une
partie de ses oeuvres qui seront partir
des états unis c'est moi celle là on les
lui confisquera pas et donc je vais sur
demande et c'est cette histoire était
pas une légende moi je crois pas moi je
crois que c'est toute la série dick
c'est extraordinaire alors ça se serait
passé avant l'occupation alors que
guernica était encore à paris ce qui est
possible aussi non je pense que ça s'est
passé pendant l'occupation
vous pensez que vous oui parce que les
gens ils ont montré une carte postale
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
c'est pas le vrai tableau toute façon
elle tenait pas elle tenait pas elle et
elle tenait pas les tells l'atelier de
la rue de la rue des grands-augustins
c'était tout petit elle tenait pas un
droit qua non mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que cette oeuvre
elle a été elle a servi pour lever des
fonds pour les républicains espagnols et
picasso a donné beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'argent mais il n'a jamais dit
ça pour v à l'époque pouces c'est vrai
que il faut se souvenir de ça on pensait
que c'était l'espagne qui sortirait
l'europe des fascismes très important et
lui était la voix de l'espagne
il avait même été nommé directeur
honoraire du prado car les républicains
espagnols par le premier ministre c'est
très important
il a été bon il était très visible et
cette oeuvre allie talent et en
angleterre à l'état les ans en allemagne
à l'état ne veulent tous alors pendant
que cette oeuvre se balader alfred barre
avait fait déjà 2 exposition picasso
fait une expression qui s'appelle un
picasso fougueuse office or 40 ans de
l'art dit il à 300 oeuvres
et puis quels sont près de 60
l'exposition commence en juillet 1939
mais comme c'est la guerre elle se passe
au moma à new york
alfred barre de mana picasso est ce que
je peux la faire tourner dans l'ensemble
des etats unis puisque je peux plus vous
renvoyer vos hommes et en fait picasso
accepte et l'oeuvre fait le tour des
états unis elle est vue par près de cinq
cent mille personnes
et pendant que picasso lui qui a demandé
la naturalisation française le 3 avril
40 et à qui on l'a refusée et est en
train d'être enfermé chez lui dans la
rue des grands augustins son oeuvre de
300 oeuvres de toutes les banques depuis
la période rose à la période cubiste à
la à la période surréaliste voyages aux
états unis et son oeuvre porte son
message et son oeuvre le rend
extrêmement célèbre aux etats unis c'est
pour ça que quand la france est libéré
par les américains
il se précipite les américains vers
picasso qui pour eux est très célèbre
alors qu'en france picasso est invisible
inconnus alors c'est ça que vous
racontez pas bien ces cas au moment-même
vous l'avais dit en avril 39 s'il va
demander pour la première et la dernière
fois il va demander à être naturalisé
français et pour cause l'espagne est
devenu fasciste il est donc apatrides
il est il est un étranger en france un
étranger suspecte donc et l'allemagne
riffs que d'envahir la france
l'allemagne le traite d'artistes
artistes dégénéré et il est dans la
liste des artistes de générer les mêmes
tout en haut de la liste
donc il manque sa naturalisation
française et elle est refusée puisqu'il
est victime
on le voit ici c'est le vous l'avez
sorti cette demande de naturalisation et
il est il est refusé pour les même
raisons qu'en 1900 anarchiste à cause de
l'égo string à cause des dossiers 19
cents à cause de nos chaînes 1900 il a
mis en mettant le pied à paris il a
multiplié dans un piège et ce piège-là
la bloquer au moment précis où ils
avaient besoin de se sentir protégé en
fait
et est ce que j'ai fait c'est que je me
suis dit il faut que je trouve le nom de
l'homme qui a signé 7 se refuse de
naturalisation voilà les deux signatures
celle de picasso en eau qui est
magnifique
un homme qui ne doute pas et puis celle
du fonctionnaire de police alors j'ai
cherché je me suis fait aider par des
spécialistes d'historienne la police
parce qu'il faut vraiment être très fort
et on a trouvé
je laisse je laisse au lecteur le
plaisir de découvrir cette enquête
policière qui est mon livre parce que
c'est une histoire rocambolesque
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous du
personnage ah ben c'est l'archétype du
fonctionnaire de police non
fonctionnaires de police veulent
médiocre hyper hyper collabos jaloux et
qui ne sait même pas de nous et nos
folles bandiat qui est picasso qui
connaît pas la peinture de picasso ou
connais parce qu'il l'a il la redoute
lui dit que picasso préfère placer ses
oeuvres à l'étranger en face et c'est
c'est l'archétype de l'horreur quoi et
on se dit comment est ce possible que ce
pays qui produit des personnalités
tellement formidable qui vont aider
picasso parce que j'en cite beaucoup ce
livre c'est aussi je pense une
radioscopie de la france vous voyez il
ya beaucoup de personnages inconnus que
je dévoile puisqu'elle se savait
s'entourer
ils avaient construit un espèce de
ministères autour de lui il ya quelqu'un
qui s'appelle andrey level qui est un
homme merveilleux
il y avait des fonctionnaires d'état qui
ont fait des gestes extraordinaires mais
olivier sincère il y avait andré level y
avait plus tard il y aura romuald dor de
la souchère des grands personnages
etienne de beaumont et puis il ya aussi
des des xénophobies en face et les deux
françaises et de deux facettes de la
france pendant l'occupation finalement
il n'est pas pas vraiment inquiété
picasso
il est il a dit ladd et des allemands
qui viennent le voir en tout cas je peux
vous dire qu'ils avaient peur ça regarde
vrai regardez regardez ce qui pendant
cette période là il parle des choses
horribles y peint des crânes de des
crânes d'animaux il peint des dd visage
torturé et fait d'eux non c'est une
période terriblement douloureuse
non il ya des des allemands qui lie à
des nazis qui vont le voir et qui vont
inquiéter
mais ce qu'il a fait de très brillant
c'est quoi il était il était
opportuniste il était ami avec des gens
très opposés il était ami avec eluard
qui veut pas l'élu et le poète qui
venait d'adhérer au parti communiste et
il avait été ami avec cocteau jean
cocteau jean cocteau est l amie d'arnaud
breaker le sculpteur préféré de hitler
qui a une exposition à paris et jean
cocteau a même fait un texte atroce qui
s'appelle hommage à brecker salut à toi
brecker donc picasso voilà il avait des
amis des deux côtés est très très
opposés il a réussi à à louvoyer parce
que ce qu'ils avaient appris chez son
ami pedro villa le le vieux monsieur de
gros saule contrebandiers ils avaient
appris à trouver des stratégies dans les
interstices de la société entre les
institutions et ça c'est s était
redoutable très très intelligente
picasso
comprenez les situations avant qu'elle
n'arrive et primes picasso anticipé et
ça c'est une qualité que très peu de
gens ou surtout très peu d'artistes en
fait et c'est ça qui lui a permis de
repérer les lieux où il fallait mettre
les pieds et c'est ce qui va le faire
adhérer au parti communiste français
l'adhésion à la libération octobre 44
voilà ils cherchent dites-vous à la fois
un bouclier est un tremplin il a
l'intuition que le parti communiste peut
lui donner l'un et l'autre voilà il ya
une exposition des oeuvres de picasso
fait pendant l'occupation des oeuvres
très noire à paris au salon d'automne en
1944 et c'est une émeute
parce que picasso n'est pas connue dans
le grand public français il ya eu deux
expositions de picasso en france public
pendant le front populaire en 37 mais
sinon le grand public ne le connaît pas
il faut savoir qu'il a déjà plus de 60
ans la wii et on sait le picasso on le
voit toujours comme un jeune homme qui a
réussi
oui mais qui n'est pas célèbre en france
seraient non non non c'est un illustre
visibles et donc l'adhésion parti
communiste le 4 octobre 1944 va
radicalement changer la donne cette
adhésion
c'est un call à la fois qu'ils reçoivent
et le coeur à gauche
picasso était démocrate picasso a aidé
les républicains espagnols dont il y
avait une immense sincérité dans ce
geste mais il y avait plus que ça il y
avait certainement de un peu
d'opportunisme puisque dès que picasso
adhèrent et on sait bien que en octobre
le parti communiste français c'est le
grand parti de france et le parti des
fusillés
c'est le parti qui avait aidé les
étrangers immédiatement picasso reçoit
des lettres des maires des municipalités
communistes des régions des directeurs
de musées des municipalités communistes
camarades picasso prête nous ça après
2006 et donc on va avoir j'ai trouvé un
dossier aux archives picasso de
personnes avaient regardé qui s'appelle
le dossier eu 14 quai vers un titre
totalement rébarbatif picasso et les
institutions muséales de province ont
des tonnes mais j'ai trouvé un trésor y
avait des lettres de saint-etienne des
led de ales délai de boulogne-sur-mer
d'elle
de castres délai vous pouvez pas savoir
j'en ai compté près de 80 municipalités
qui lui disent ils lui demandent conseil
qui est picasso au frais venez je vous
donnerai moins de la main à la main une
céramique une toile donc il a dès 1944
fourbi
les musées des régions françaises
d'oeuvre d'avant garde
mais je dirais à ce point de vue là que
picasso est un vecteur de modernisation
du pays bien avant et de
décentralisation bien avant jacques lang
vous dites aussi que dira d'ailleurs il
va équipe paris et ils s'installent sur
la côte d'azur à 45 équipes paris il
choisit le sud
donc il choisit le sud contre le nord
les artisans contre l'académie des
beaux-arts qui l'a tellement bt et il
choisit les honneurs des municipalités
de région notamment citoyen honoraire de
vallauris citoyen honoraire d'antibes
tout en refusant la légion d'honneur et
en refusant que malraux lee propose et
en refusant la naturalisation française
que lui offre sur un plateau d'intro de
georges pompidou est trop tard il a
l'ambition d'être revenu à la libération
parce que là il ya un moment quand même
pied qui et c'est une immense star on
l'a dit et il vient d'adhérer au parti
communiste et l'état français se rend
compte alors il ya deux oeuvres de
picasso et collections publiques mais
c'est très très peu et puis y'a pas que
picasso qui a été méprisée il ya toutes
les avant-gardes donc l'état français
décide d'acheter enfin les stars de
l'avant garde donc mathis qui à yar où
il ya ces annonces et anne était mort
mais il y avait il y avait match et
picasso qui pressait il veut rentrer
dans les musées français décide lui de
donner ces abris landis est donc enfin
il va ya voir picasso entre au musée
solennellement officiellement alors que
vous l'avais dit il ya eu si souvent des
oeuvres qui étaient prévus pour aller
dans les musées qui ont été refusées par
les musées français
là y en a dix qui rentre d'un coup c'est
un début de reconnaissance
oui absolument ça vient d'un homme jean
cassou qui était directeur du musée
national d'art moderne et ça vient du
directeur des musées de france qui
s'appelle georges salles étaient des
gens très bien et qui disait voilà il y
en a et il faut absolument finir avec
cette politique acéistes il faut qu'ils
aient des des contemporains et le jour
où les alors georges salle fait je vous
raconter une histoire ça va vous plaire
georges salle 10 à picasso le louvre est
fermé le
hardy
les oeuvres que nous nous offrez si
généreusement je voudrais que vous je
vais les emmener au louvre pendant la
nuit et je demanderai aux travailleurs
du louvre enfin au au garde de l'est de
les poser à côté des oeuvres que je vous
choisissez des grands maîtres anciens et
vous viendrez puisqu'elle sera content
c'est françoise gilot qui raconte sa
compagne de l'époque que picasso les
places à côté de ce barrage à côté de
courbet à côté de delacroix et il a
cette immense plaisir de voir ses
propres oeuvres
à côté des grands maîtres a dit loulou
c'est ce sera le sujet de l'exposition
picasso et senna et les maîtres les
maîtres qui sera au louvre-lens pendant
que moi je suis commissaire d'une
exposition au musée de la porte dorée un
musée national de l'histoire de
l'immigration exactement au même moment
s'appellera picasso l'étranger j'espère
que vous viendrez oui parce que ce sera
une belle exposition je leur en fait le
lendemain quand les oeuvres arrive au
musée national d'art moderne georges
salle prononce cette phrase que je
trouve magnifique
aujourd'hui c'est sans fin en france le
divorce entre l'état et le génie et 2 en
1 une année plus tard une lettre de la
préfecture de police au ministère de
l'intérieur venait veuillez donner à
très célèbres artistes picasso une carte
de résident privilégiées et s'il ne peut
pas venir qu'il envoie quelqu'un a eu
dix ans il avait acheté 40 ans
d'ostracisation picasso rentre enfin
dans le dans les petits papiers de la
république française
mais au même moment aux états unis ya 12
heures le patron du fbi qui le désigne à
la vindicte y vient d'adhérer au parti
communiste dont il devient suspect aux
états unis ah oui c'est extraordinaire
parce que le picasso c'est un baromètre
de la géopolitique mondiale en fait il a
été donc il est entré en dans l'empiré
russe par des grands des grands
marchands tout kiné morozov
et puis après pendant la période
soviétique les oeuvres sont
nationalisées on les voit pas à ce
moment-là lui il est très célèbre aux
etats-unis et l'ue en allemagne où suez
en allemagne
et puis au moment au moment de la de la
guerre froide il devient suspect pour le
fbi américain
c'est une histoire absolument
extraordinaire et on va le est alors
alfred barre ne sait pas quoi faire
parce que c'est ces collectionneurs lui
dise
picasso est charlie chaplin picasso
alors picasso travail va donner des
gages au parti communiste français a
beaucoup hein pas beaucoup il va donner
de l'argent
il va faire quelques oeuvres pas très
belle le charnier par exemple massacre
en corée dans les années 50 5 en corée
c'est pendant la guerre de corée soit
l'agglo et oui très démonstratif voilà
on est d'accord et et surtout il va
faire cette fameuse colombes qui va être
démultipliée à des millions
d'exemplaires c'est pas grand chose il
lui prend 3,3 de miss 3 secondes et
demie de faire cette colombe
mais cette colonne sera dense sur toutes
les affiches dans le monde entier et ce
sera la signature de picasso donc en
fait la relation entre picasso et le
parti communiste
c'est quelque chose de très intéressant
parce que
picasso y voient un intérêt personnel
dans son cas en france l'irsn on a bien
vu que c'est grâce au parti communiste
qu'il devient visible en france est pour
mais en même temps que ce ne veut pas
être pris dans le la ligne du parti et
la ligne du réalisme socialiste de
peindre comme un artiste deux parties
n'en veut pas donc il va y avoir ce
moment extraordinaire de la mort de
staline 1952 ou aragon ou directeurs des
lettres françaises demandent à picasso
est ce que tu peux pas faire un portrait
de staline et picasso il est à vallauris
à ce moment-là envoie un portrait de
staline jeunes avec un coût et l'on est
dans une chemise blanche et qui fait un
scandale risque pourquoi c'est un
scandale de lèse majesté puisqu'on est
en plein dans le culte de la
personnalité stalinien et picasso lui il
leur présente comme un homme un homme du
commun quoi et pas comme le comme ces
espèces de sein ou de héros qu'on avait
qu'on avait qu'on avait célébré
alors il a dit souvent il a dit des
trucs très très bon là dessus il a dit
mais comment tu veux que je le rends
compte que je leur présente staline je
le connais pas je n'ai jamais vu pour
moi c'est un mec qui avait une à une
veste avec beaucoup de boutons dorés une
grosse moustache d une casquette ou
alors il aurait fallu que je le fasse à
poil mais son zizi il était grand il
était petit c'est extraordinaire de dire
des choses comme ça donc en fait il est
picasso à l'interdît parti communiste et
un poids formidable pour le parti
communiste
mais en même temps c'était un lutin
irrévérencieux il est difficile à gérer
qui va le sortir de cette mauvaise passe
donc ça fait scandale auprès des
militants etc
c'est maurice thorez
extraordinaire le secrétaire du parti
communiste français et picasso avait une
ligne directe il s'adoraient il se
respectaient thorel avait 25 ans de
moins mais ils adorent et picasso il
adorait le pois de picasso et le dossier
que maurice thorez à regarder maurice
thorez d'anomie immensément cultiver né
dans un comm ouvriers de fils d'ouvriers
la trêve stalinien oui aussi exaltant
mais la seule fois que torres est sorti
de sa ligne c'est pour protéger picasso
et le dossier portraits de staline
à noter par thorez c'est fascinant il ya
du rouge partout etc storez qui va
sortir picasso de cette mauvaise passe
en lui demandant d'ennuis en de venir le
voir
et quand il rentre de moscou après trois
années où il était soigné à moscou c'est
picasso que torres voit en premier donc
il va absoudre picasso il va protéger
picasso mais c'est surtout picasso qui
se débrouille pour être
au dessus des des histoires d'appareils
et au dessus des lignes de parti c'est
extra extra ordinaire on fire s'en
sortait pour finir nikon seul alors il
ya la grande exposition hommage à
picasso en 1966 andré malraux ministre
de la culture
donc là tout à coup la ya 800 oeuvres ne
grand palais le petit palais la
bibliothèque nationale là ça y est c'est
il est canonisé nicaso et puis surtout
ce cadeau de malromé qui est une loi
formidable qui est la loi sur la dation
voudrait qu'on finisse par parcelle part
ça parce que c'est très important 1
on l'a vu picasso a vécu toute sa vie en
france
la france s'en est méfié pendant la plus
grande partie de sa vie et à la fin il
va tout lui donner puisque grâce à cette
loi pour payer les frais d' de là on
appelle ça de succession de succession
la famille d'un artiste peut payer en
oeuvre d'art heureusement parce que
sinon on imagine que le le cours des
picasso se serait écroulé tellement il y
avait deux oeuvres à ce moment là et ça
c'est très important et c c'est
véritablement pour picasso que malraux
concocte c'est clairement clairement
mais je voudrais vous reprendre un peu
frédéric je dirais pas la france s'en
est méfié
oui moi je préside aux étoiles échoué
oui j'ai la france c'est beaucoup trop
globale il ya des institutions
françaises
il ya il ya des personnages français
vous voyez les institutions françaises
qui ont été brutales c'est la police et
c'est l'académie des beaux-arts mais il
ya des personnalités qui ont été
fabuleuses avec picasso et c'est celle
dont je parle
celle que je décris je décris leurs
interactions je décris les lettres je
décris les les
les rires les laisser les interventions
au sol c'est pas les français
oui d'accord il est effectivement
puisqu'elle société un personnage
extrêmement médiatique il adoré la
presse et il s'est construit cette
espèce de d'empyr dans le sud où il a
rayonné dans le monde entier il est
devenu picasso monde
à partir de cet endroit là quoi et alors
le génie de malraux ça a été de faire
voter cette loi en effet comme vous le
dites
le 31 décembre 1968 et de rattrapé de
justesse
l'oeuvre de
kasso en france puisque c'est non
seulement ces milliers d'oeuvres de
carnets de dessins sculptures de poésie
puisqu'il est devenu un très grand poète
en 1935 plus ces documents puisque piqué
souhaitait quelqu'un qui ne jetez rien
on appelle en nacre en anglais on dit de
quelqu'un qui amasse il ne l'était pas
un ticket de cirque où il était allé en
1901 au cirque medrano bon tout est là
moi c'est ça que je suis venu android et
toute sa correspondance tous ses papiers
et tous ses carnets et tous et toutes
ses cartes d'identité et donc cette
masse de documents étalés à la france et
c'est ça qui a permis l'ouverture de
picasso en 1904 du musée picasso à
l'hôtel salé en 1985 et donc et cette
création du mythe picasso si vous voulez
mais par là même la création de ce mythe
picasso et de ce musée a oblitéré les
quarante années qui ont précédé
d'autant que picasso n'en a jamais parlé
bon là je suis entré dans quelque chose
de très intime et je me suis parfois
demandé si j'avais le droit de rendre
compte de cela mais comme on a cette
espèce de magistère picasso
qui règne maintenant sur le xxème siècle
je me suis dit que pour tous les jeunes
artistes pour tous les gens qui s'ouvre
pour tous les étrangers
ren savoir que picasso a vécu
ces événements-là à ces scandales qu'il
en a triomphé c'est une très belle
histoire ne doit pas mais en même temps
il ya il ya un contre coup et ça c'est
qu'on a vécu avec l'idée que les avant
gardes ont toujours été refusés et par
l'académisme et pas les autorités et par
les états vous et est depuis maintenant
on va dire depuis les années 60 mais
surtout depuis les années 70 et 80
c'est le contraire les avant gardes sont
célébrés par les autorités par les
musées parlée par les gouvernements on
adore les avant-gardes ce qui fait qu'il
ya plus d'avant garde
ce qui fait que au fond il ya un art
officiel aujourd'hui picasso n'a jamais
été l'art officiel
mathis non plus n'ont ni les fauves ni
même les impressionnistes
ils sont devenus un peu l'académisme ni
un moment les impressionnisme mais ils
sont jamais devenus l'art officiel
aujourd'hui un art officiel
ça dépend des madeleines à part leur de
se tromper que au fond aujourd'hui
toutes toutes les avant-gardes et
défauts ça vous regarde sur les
bienvenus oui mais je vais vous dire ça
dépend des pays frédéric en faisais tu
as we en france à vous parler de la
france et je veux dire les états unis
c'est pas du tout géré comme la france
la prime minister ministre de la culture
il ya des beaucoup plus libre les
collectionneurs ont beaucoup plus le
droit de parler dans les musées etc
vous voyez donc il se trouve que fillon
effectivement picasso et la bousculer
les choses
il a bousculé les rapports avec la
famille il ay là il a inventé une
famille recomposée
il a fait imposer son nom à ses enfants
qu'il avait hors mariage avec françoise
gilot il a il ya énormément de choses
qu'il a il a bousculé un pays qui était
un peu archaïque et des institutions un
peu archaïque
on lui doit énormément les et je dois
dire que c'est ça la leçon de ce livre
en fait c'est sais ce que cet homme a
apporté à la france malgré le début
terrible de son parcours quoi et c'est
vrai que moi j'ai découvert quelqu'un
d'impressionnant quoi une force de la
nature une une une une intelligence à
l'oeuvre une une
un génie colossal quoi quelque part je
crois que c'est un ça devrait être un
mentor pour poulets pour tout l'est pour
tous les gens qui se posent des
questions par rapport à la france
bonjour bon pour la france pardon vous
pensez à qui je pense aux jeunes
artistes aujourd'hui si vous voulez moi
je vois ce jeune gars jeune poète
nigérian qui est publié que le
brillantissime qui n'arrive pas à avoir
ses papiers
voilà lui c'est ce jeune nigérian il
sera à l'académie française dans 70 ans
il faut il faut absolument réviser
certaines attitudes qui sont aujourd'hui
qui ont été néfastes à des à des
personnages comme maire on est dans une
période similaire à l'époque on avait
très peur de l'immigration des étrangers
les étrangers étaient suspects on est
redevenu une décision comme ça on ne
dirait pas où il ya une france qui est
ouverte il ya une france qui est fermé
il ya une france qui est chaleureuse et
une france qui revêt ch
je dirai pas où je veux pas généraliser
les gens qui ont aidé picasso qui ont
vous savez un étranger ne sait pas aller
dans un gérer ses problèmes
administratifs au camp personne ne sait
le faire donc picasso pot pour lui la
personne qui l'a fait c'est andré level
d'andré level il a géré pour picasso
toutes les relations avec à la fois le
ministère de l'intérieur les impôts etc
il a tout fait pour lui un étranger ne
sait pas faire ça c'est très très
difficile
on sait très hostile un pays étranger
l'admistration interdit c'est comme un
labyrinthe
c'est pas étonnant picasso y peint des
aveugles il n'est pas le minotaure
aveugle même en 1931 il ya quelque chose
de qui terrorise et et et c'est pas on
sait certains individus qui vont prendre
la l'étranger par la main et faire les
démarches avec lui mais picasso ce
qu'ils enseignent c'est que personne
n'est victime c'est qu'on est agent de
sa propre vie on sai les traits sartrien
ont construit sa vie dans les
interstices de la société le livre
s'intitule un étranger nommé picasso et
des signes annie cohen-solal et il est
paru aux éditions fayard merci annie
n'avoir pas c'est toute cette émission
avec nous merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]